>>> DD GHORCASES.
,000 NEWAND THEDEMIC SO  VOTERS
>> BASED ON MY FRIE
ESVE AHELE IT.
>> JOHNY IS TALKING HO S
RS B WON'T >> WE WEREBEGINNING,
OUR COUNTRKEINESS. HAPPENED.
ALL HE SUCCEED DOING U MARKET A
TH GONE TO POTE COROY I RETIREDN
THE FACE OF A NEW CAMPAIGN
WORRY, LOSING THE SENIOR VOTE.AE
TOVCASE FLORI65ND M OF THE VOTE
20.
POPOLLS NOW SHOW JOEEN WITH AN.
FOR TRUMP THERE'S
PA WINNING WITHOUTLORIDA MESENT
HCHANGEIES. DO
>>
PARTY.ONSIDERS HERSELF A  A TRU
OF IED I WAS WRONG N
TI A GOOD PRENT HAPPEN.
>> HE WISHES PRESIDENT WOULD
DO ONETHING.
>>DE S
E DOINGU KNOW WE SUPPORT HIM.  P
WON BY 1 PERCENT POINT THE
SAME MARGIEAR
ATE.RATS HAVE SEEN VOTERGISTRAT.
>> THERE AREHA TO BE IEARS PAST
>> DO YOU KNOWPLTEDRUMP LASTIME
GOIHISME?
>>LLY I KNOW RA SON GRHEVE ALREA
QUESONBIS FIT
OFFICE.
MUCHUNGER, BUT IE I THINK INHEO
SUOU WITH THE
PEOP,E WRONG PLACE TO TALK ABOU
COUNTY'SOP BELIEVES HIS
RE A WILL
RE-E
>>IS AS STR AS S GEARS F A MOTG
>> TRDO I'VEEE
BEFORE.
>> THERE'S NOUESTION FOUARNS ANW